he told me off so I was using a plastic
drinking straw he said that's bad that
is single-use plastic
hopefully what you mean he says that
single-use plastic after you've used
that to drink up gem and tonic it's
gonna go into the sea and kill a turtle
said well then it's not single-use
plastic hello welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster
I'm Konstantin kisum and this is the
show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a fantastic
comedian one of our favorites Leo curse
welcome to trigonometry hello Francis
hello Konstantin thanks for having me
the voice is so different to the way you
said you're talking like usually doesn't
say you never totally that in real life
it's like my mind says the forenoon if
it's on that push voice yeah Francis but
you're you and good spirits man you just
come back from Australia where you were
stuck during the lockdown
yeah therefore lay almost six months so
go stuck over there cuz a coronavirus
and you stayed and I wish it stayed like
the day after left the comedy clubs
opened up again so social distance if it
knows up to three hundred people allowed
in venues they don't have any
coronavirus there and I've come back to
the UK and there's new gigs and appears
to be some sort of race war as well yeah
but it did see the world is going in a
very strange direction isn't it like
what do you make of it cuz you've you've
been abroad you really haven't been part
of the whole like Dominic Cummings end
of the world and they let all that chair
and you come back and suddenly as you
say it seems to be very very serious
right now than that yeah absolutely I
don't know if it's part of is the
response to coronavirus everybody's been
like you know just stuck in their houses
for months on end and like just
festering and ready to you know it's
like it's like I was pressure cooker
ready to blow off you know I mean a bit
half of the people that were at the
demonstrations were just looking for an
excuse to get the house okay um but yeah
I mean obviously I'm gonna watch they're
always the Martha of the George flight
in its late I mean it's shocking it's
real visceral sub and so such a clear
symbol of the sort of the the racism
inherent and and the police the systemic
racism because not only is a guy killing
him but he's doing it being filmed
surrounded by police officers he knows
he's not gonna get into trouble so and
so yeah that was I mean I was really
shocked and I think you know something
that vessel that emotional is obviously
gonna you know people are gonna rise up
I mean thank [ __ ] it's like you know
it's actually making real change in
policing and also across wider society
so I mean a thing in the UK we went
through that with the Stephen Lawrence
inquiry and the 90s and so the you know
the police took big steps to address
assistance systemic racism within you
know institutional racism within the
ranks and hopefully that's that's know
happen in America but it's kind of its
kind of overdue sorry a piece of CDs as
it's true in like you know I can totally
see what I mean the one thing is white
walk people wasted no time at all like
making it all about themselves and you
don't making things worse straight out
there I've seen them like I've seen the
one face but the stuff you see on social
media have seen white people renouncing
renouncing the white privilege so you
can't renounce it just no white billowy
third answer is to do black because
definitely I'm gonna make things worse
you know I mean you can't reduce your
weight privilege did you did you buy
yeah I saw lots of people with books did
you get some books and then do an
Instagram story about it man none of
those people are gonna read those books
I've seen people post in for is of like
50 books on colonialism and like you
know
systemic racism and stuff they're gonna
read them know they're not gonna read
those books like that's this we think
it's like a it's like a thing that
though it's just them performative you
know it's virtue signaling and also a
lot of these books are saw there's one
there's one called it's called something
ridiculous like how to talk to black
people are some is written by a white
person and the whole thing is just sort
of all this guide
that you've got to like go through when
you're talking to a black person as if
like the you know what white people need
when they're talking to black people is
more of a stick up their eyes I think
what people need to do is just they need
to make honestly to meet people less
racist it's got to be simple and I think
you know simple rules nobody's like some
people are gonna read 58 books most
people aren't going to read 50 books
those guys that were protecting war
memorials and doing Nazi salutes they're
not gonna read 58 books you need to make
it simple like just something like don't
be a dick and like you know lesson and
you know if somebody raises something
then lesson and take it and see it from
their point of view and stuff as that
it's got to be at the moment like what
people are trying to make an enemy of
quite a big swath of the the population
and I really think you know people need
to be brought on board and you know led
to be led to be less racist you can't
like you can't batter them over their
head there's a in psychology there's a
there's a thing called psychological
reactants so you want to do that if
somebody comes in like you know shows
that you to tell you not to do something
you want to do that thing yeah you know
there's a it's a it's a it's a weird and
you know disincentive so and you see it
with censorship you know if something
censored then then people wanted find it
they want to search I'm gonna find it
when I see it
and I think it's the same with with I
say you know if you show somebody and
scream at something and call them names
you're not gonna win them over to your
side of the argument we need to like
make it easier for people to be less
racist to make it you know a nice thing
to do and not battering them over their
head but so recognizing their point of
view and bringing them with us I mean
apart from the guys didn't I salute you
he's gonna get done for inciting to
violence so we'd like to publicly
distance ourselves or anybody who wants
to kill Nancy not and to the few people
who are who have that persuasion we
realize you're not Nazis your national
mission is very different but but
actually so basically what you're saying
leo is cancelling Little Britain isn't
gonna stop racism oh man all these TV
she was getting cancelled I just please
into the hands of the far-right because
they've already got a narrative of white
British culture been under attack which
you know is the certain extent you know
khatma cockney
doesn't what we said the Cockney tribe
the cockneys world and the Amazon or
Papua New Guinea you know all these like
you know walk laughs these would be
trying to preserve their culture yeah
gives their way every light now [ __ ] you
guys you know I mean go asacs come buy a
house in Essex you know I mean take your
daily deals with you and you know I
think there's this narrative and the
fire rate of you know white British
culture been under attack so if you
cancel all these much-loved TV shows
you're just playing into that narrative
I mean though their sin their sin
they're looking at cancelling some
episodes of Only Fools and Horses taking
them though I mean you might as well
[ __ ] directly into the Queen's mouths
you know I mean that is just like such a
red flag and none of it's being done by
people of color all the TV executives
they're always well-meaning walk lefties
they're all like Oxbridge educated white
people this way we need more like being
like representation and they and their
arts and executive positions in the
media because they're not gonna make
stupid position they're not gonna cancel
Only Fools and Horses as some sort of
gesture to make themselves look good you
know I mean if there's more like black
executives in the BBC I might have a
chance of getting on it but actually you
bring up an interesting point because
enjoy joking aside I'm gonna show you if
it's about bein representations I
probably more about working-class
representation yeah you think I think
that's really the issue and very often
when they do diversify stuff it yeah
it's the same Oxbridge graduates just
with a different skin color but they all
work lefties as you say yeah as opposed
to actually get genuine diversity and we
see it with people of color as well and
you know a lot of the people they get
like you know in NASH kumara whoever
they're the people of color but they've
got the same Oxbridge you know lefty
voice that you know all the white
comedians do so you know there's not so
much you know there's there's a there's
amazing amazing diversity of voices on
the on the club circuit but they don't
all make it onto TV it tends to be just
that
strata of the Oxbridge educated lefties
you really like this don't you nothing
against him and he slide me off on stage
and it's like doing don't slag me off
you know I mean because I'll be on
grudge
mummy went to see him in and bruh and he
was on some
compilation short he was drunk and it
was [ __ ] apparently and it's like it's
like off right-wing comedians and like
named me and I can't remember who else
raising all the other right-wing
comedians from the field you know the
one right-wing comedian so you psyched
you off yeah and then you've been
sagging him off ever since twice twice I
didn't really slag him up I just used
him as an example of you know this sort
of like you know it said on the surface
it looks like diversity but you know
it's not really diversity there's much
more you know genuinely culturally and
whatever else the various voices out
there and he's I mean I may not be
articulating that very well but from I'm
from rural Scotland for fun season like
you know people mind they're like you as
somebody who's done a degree you know
they'll attack somebody like Tyson Fury
the bill are his opinions are terrible
so yeah he hasn't been working on his
opinions he hasn't done like you know
eight years phd's in like gender studies
and stuff course he's got terrible
opinions he's been learning to get
really good at boxing like why don't
people like nobody talks about like
these people who've done all these
Gender Studies degree being being [ __ ] a
boxing if you focus on your opinions
you're gonna get really good at Pena so
if you folks overlook some box you're
gonna get good at boxing I mean it's
it's a good point I'm not we're having a
laugh about it but the reality is is
that if you've got opinions which are
not going to be the correct ones yeah
you're not gonna get as far as you
probably should yeah that's true for
example yes so explain to people who
might not know about Edinburgh why
Dubrow so important as a comedian and
why is it so important to get noticed
and to progress yeah I mean is a big set
of industry cattle market where all the
comedian's go we do our shows all the
industries there then go and see the
shows and yeah I mean it'd be silly I
mean for me it's a it's an opportunity
to make some money and and right and you
show it forces you to write I mean I
think n Burroughs an actual important
thing for a comedian getting picked up
by the BBC or whatever is diminishing
less and less like social media is
becoming so much more important and
videos in YouTube
whatever but yeah I mean it's you know
traditionally that's why Eddie but it
was important what was the question
maybe you might disagree with it I don't
think you will but isn't it a
fundamentally biased system and way of
doing things the Edinburgh Festival yeah
in the industry is still still hugely
biased towards a middle-class walk
University educated lefties the industry
is run by by white walk lefties and you
know anybody who doesn't fit that fit
into that mold doesn't doesn't get much
of a looking and what is welcoming to
you because we use that term and we all
say woke this woke that what is
welcoming to you is quite assertive
rigid ideology those shifts over time
like what what one week won't be walk
the next week every decision last week
stairs like I noticed recently somebody
used a new term for being people so you
know with them you know with people of
color you know it valve to beam and then
I know it's by POC which brought black
indigenous black and indigenous and
black indigenous and people of color are
ranked and there was a reason there was
a reason that did start make sense about
why you'd use that but then like
anybody's using the world terminology
you know I mean is like me a grand that
comes out and you know you some sort of
races usually hasn't been up there isn't
lanta of malice or in and then is just
what they've been taught by the lake
walk culture is always and nobody's ever
gonna be it's almost like him like is
with walk culture nothing's ever pure
enough like this religious purity and
they've constantly got to apologize and
atone for sins that you may not have
even committed you know I mean sins of
your forefathers
you've got to apologize for sleeve it
I'm no I'm not being funny but like I
don't I don't mind sister's own slaves a
little a tiny proportion I think my own
sisters were just digging a you know
feeling full of turnips somewhere and
having a [ __ ] time and he's got to
apologize for all this stuff and it's
almost like they've repackaged
Catholicism you know this this constant
sort of a tool this is religious purity
that you're never gonna you're never
gonna attain and also the constant
atonement and you know absorbing
yourself and then feeling better because
you've done that
if there's something innate in people
that wants to do that when it every
Sunday was to confess their sins and say
they're gonna be a better person and
read these books on racial justice you
know [ __ ] kid too much yeah we can cut
that out but staying by Park I didn't
know about it like I think between the
did all of these different groups
they're gonna capture most of the
alphabet very soon on hmm right I mean
the thing is once you you know make this
acronym acronyms big enough like LGBTQ
is you know going on to I parts of I
plus and stuff I know it includes me
we've included me and that thing so so
they've got me turning up to the part
isn't there like who the folks who this
K know they're not really bit like that
transgender lassie and I went to do a
show about empowerment council I was a
visa I did this I did I did this show a
right-wing comedian like a couple years
back well last year in Australia in fact
and obviously like a name like I got
people's backs up in the arts community
because you know they're all for
diversity but not diversity of opinion
you know there's got distinct of this
rigid sort of walk lefty narrative you
know you kind of any mainstream opinions
so yes I was doing the show right when
comedian people people went on to try
and try and get me cancel the dog
through my stuff went through my Twitter
went all the way back to that afternoon
and found that posted and it was it was
about em little bit the the deference in
transitioning between men and women oh
it's you know is you know people talk
about male privilege because people talk
about how is others male privilege but I
think it's tough being a man you know
that's why so many of us are
transitioning is we harder for somebody
like me to transition to being a woman
than Ezra woman to transition to being a
man lie about what transitioned to being
a woman it's a full extensive thing
woman once the trends that him to be in
a man basically she she stops shaving
and you know grows a beard that people
may be like you know I think that mines
good text you know like if I were if I
want a transition to being a woman
there's
there's all these hormones surgery all
the rest of I got to go through and
people got really offended that material
was transforming it wasn't intended to
be transphobic it was just looking at
the differences in the experience
between men and women and you know it's
just it's just the fact that the man who
transitioned to the women pass a less
convincingly in society than women who
transition to me because you get small
famine and men like you too small now
he's lost a lot of weight
basically I locked myself in my flat for
three months I can't cook and I had a
breakdown right yeah it's a good way do
it
yeah yeah we had an actual mental break
though no anyway it was a joke well I
mean it's inevitable next time I get
cancelled which I will be which I will
be what are we talking we're talking
about smaller men oh yes so you get you
get a small effeminate men so like you
know women who transitions have been a
model or past but you tend not to get
you know large masculine women you know
the prominent brow bone and the jaw bone
and all the rest of it so when we
transition men who transition to women
don't always pass as well now it's just
a recognized thing but people people say
people aren't as they're people are you
know aren't as well informed as me but
think that their walk accused I accuse
me of being transphobic and got me
cancelled from my venue and my veins
pulled me straight away they just said
you know this is an inclusive space you
have to leave and yeah like what do you
make a Malia because there's a lot of
people in the world of comedy who like
you know we've probably used the term
work lefties like 20 times in the course
of this interview there'd be like well
yeah but it's never the funny comedians
that are complaining about censorship
and comedy like all this kind of thing
like did you think maybe we go too far
sometimes and we talk about all the
censorship when actually we can all kind
of do the stuff that we want to do is
that I mean I think censorship is it can
be quite
subtle thing hmm you know even just even
just the self-censorship that you feel
most most censorship is invisible as you
put on you by yourself the artists sense
was a fear so I mean if you're in a
repressive regime then you know like Ron
or Bernie or something then you're gonna
sell sense and you're gonna mention the
Sultan or whatever as I'm an eidetic in
Brunei last year and what comedy is
illegal and you know obvious I wasn't
allowed to mention the Sultan but also I
mean it made it exciting because it was
illegal but I bet you're trans material
one time yes I think that I think I just
did like regular Club stuff mm-hmm but
even like you know talking a bit
shagging and stuff I mean just the act
of doing comedy in Brunei is you know
you're not allowed to do it yeah yes
under a repressive regime that's the
kind of censorship you do are you saying
that that's kind of what we're doing
here as well we we self censor because
if somebody comes out and you know does
anything you know if you question the
the walk narrative then you know you get
shadowing people you know and see it
they say are you it's a dog whistle for
racism and stuff or you're apologizing
for these four right-wing people or
whatever and yeah that can have as much
of an impact and also I mean there's
there's a comedy club Booker's who admit
that they won't they won't boot me I
mean most comedy club because though
they want to make money they want every
to have a good time they know I'm not
spoken you know hateful stuff and he if
you spoke if you genuinely did hateful
stuff onstage at a comedy night it
wouldn't work because you don't need the
sense of comedians there's already a
jury in front of us judging us
constantly and that's the audience if
they don't like it if they think that
we're being you know racist sexist
homophobic they're not going to laugh
you've got to you've got this sort of
agree or at least recognize the the
truth that something's coming from and
and find the person likeable to be able
to laugh at them so censorship in comedy
is a bit ridiculous because it's
completely unnecessary given that we're
constantly self censoring and constantly
in that feedback loop with an audience
and you seem to assume that you say that
because you know there's a comedy night
that we do all the time which is comedy
Unleashed yeah we all love them we have
a really good timer and then every once
in a while some really noble kind work
person pops up and says it's a racist
gig yeah yeah
that's the kind of thing that affects
you know know there's people saying that
they want to distance themselves from
comedy unleashed and you know it's seen
comedians that perform perform there or
like you know all right we're just
talking about me man and yeah like
that's that's censorship that feeds into
like people's self-censorship and that
feeds into people's perceptions Booker's
perceptions people in the media's
perceptions and cut-stone avenues you
know as they say it's a subtle way of
chipping away at somebody's somebody's
freedoms I guess it's not really
censorship in the sense that the
government isn't coming in and stopping
it maybe what we're really talking about
is this fever pitch you know everyone's
a Nazi or everyone's at work lefty maybe
we're doing it a little bit too like
everybody's evil you know on both sides
and therefore it feeds into this
narrative that if you don't agree with
somebody entirely then they must be evil
yeah now I I would you know like I've
seen many of your shows or performances
in clubs and whatever to be honest with
you I think you don't have to be
right-wing or even centrist to enjoy
them I think it's just great comedy but
I think what happens is if we keep being
told that this is a night that only
caters to right-wing people or whatever
yeah then it creates this false
perception yeah so I think maybe it's
not sensitive probably the wrong word
you know what I mean like it's something
yes censorship doesn't have to be this
draconian state imposed the absolutist
thing I mean it can be the this gentle
suppression of ideas and people and then
self-censorship is the I mean when we
think of censorship I think oh you know
Lenny Bruce being arrested and all this
kind of stuff but more censorship is
just self-censorship that you do
according to to what you think is gonna
be what you think is fashionable and
what you think is acceptable and what
you think is on trend was gonna what's
going to be good for you
and there's that stuff that you've not
done that you've written that you
thought this is great and it's funny and
it's not it's not hateful or anything
like that but you don't know I can't do
that yeah
yeah no absolutely I mean I was a
theater and a jillion lasted for a while
and I did stuff
[Laughter]
a cultural eye-opener for me there's
there's you know cultural differences
between us the really I mean I didn't
know about the weaves I didn't know
about the weaves remember I was kissing
her I was like where's these novels in
your head and she's like it's my weave
and I'm like what is a weave she's like
you don't know what a weave is I'm like
no I was like no way you like did you
think this is my real hair and I was
like yeah I didn't know and so there's
all that sort of you know culture clash
stuff but I found you know when I when I
spoke a bit on stage some audiences
later but sometimes I could just feel
are so starting to clinch a little bit
you know I'm talking about this sort of
em you know racial interplay and you
just before you jump in Francis do you
find like I always find it was like four
months ago whenever when we did comedy
but I've always found that if you do
stuff about race which is what you're
talking about or anything like that
it's in my experience and maybe I'm
judging and maybe I'm wrong but my
experience is always the middle class
woke people were white that don't like
it yeah and it's usually the minorities
who are laughing their heads off but
yeah so really what what I feel is it's
not so much that people from those
communities are becoming more easily
offended it's it's the white woke middle
class people who are being offended on
their behalf the events of Li Jie's that
yeah absolutely I mean walk white people
love to get offended on other people's
behalf and they love to try and fix
problems that aren't you know they're
not best placed to fix I mean if history
is showing us anything it's the
oppressed marginalized people are their
own best advocates like we we should
just sit back and let them speak and
support them and you know Martin Luther
King's Speech wouldn't have been
improved if some white guy and a black
lights my t-shirt bars from out the
wings we're gonna part that for a moment
cuz I also do dream I was riding a
giraffe with the cheeky girls you know
and whatever you know it's well I think
what white people always try and like
take a faint trying take a fence and
other people's behalf and also try and
fix things and it's usually backfires
it's really interesting when you watch
comedy from like 10 years ago by even
old episodes of Mock the Week with
Frankie boy on them from 12 years ago
and you are absolutely just
flabbergasted at what they got away live
he said something right even it's a
committee with us a bit near they're not
cool yeah everybody laughs do you think
we've become more censorious in comedy
now oh absolutely I mean even Frankie
Boyle himself he made all his money
doing these outrageous hilarious jokes
about completely unjustifiable things
like there's no way you can justify that
jokey did about Jordans kid harm right
you know this and that's that joke is
got everything it's er it's a rape joke
it's misogynist it says it's racial it's
like everything and no joke is [ __ ]
horrible
and now letter B made loads of money off
it yeah he made a lot of Matt and now
he's turned around he's like ah
everybody else shouldn't be doing you
know I shouldn't be doing these every
got to be walk now so I hope you give
that money that you made doing these
[ __ ] horrible jokes I mean they're
very funny give that money they like you
know other comedians aren't like to do
those jokes then you know see I would
have gone to like orphans in Africa but
no you just you just want the money me
yeah but but it's amazing isn't it and
you know all of a sudden we've come to
this point where you just can't say
certain things and you self censor
yourself directly it's gonna come a
point where we comedy is essentially not
really gonna work anymore or do you
think there's gonna be a backlash I
think there's gonna be a backlash and I
think is I think it's already started
and I think people recognize you know
mostly recognize that comedies got to be
a sort of unsafe space where we can be
outrageous and provocative cos that's
where the funny stuff is then I mean I
and it's not for everybody I mean I
watched internet and well the other one
Douglas I'm gonna trade what just I
don't get like but people are loving it
so that's that's fine they can love that
but that's not my kind of stuff I want
to watch you know a jelly sandwich and
stuff like that so people got to
recognize that just as I can't shut down
Hannah Gadsby we shouldn't be able able
to shut down jelly cider wits or
Bilborough or whoever I want to watch
hello guys and welcome back to my
bedroom a que la maison del bunky
now they've got a returning sponsor for
you which is the shaving company Ares
and I've got to be honest to you I love
hair is actually using myself they give
a lovely tight finish to the skin
beautiful light razors they don't tug at
the skin so give you a little bit of a
backstory about Harry's right which is
it's it's akin to Stahl is a story of
biblical proportions there were two men
Jeff and Andy now they may sound like
they're in witness protection but
they're not all right and Jeff and Andy
got sick of being ripped off day in and
day out by razor blade companies not
fulfilling their end of the bargain so
they did what any regular person would
do they bought a factory the great thing
about Harry's is that the troll said
they provide you with gives everything
you need for a beautiful show B gives
you away dog anomic handle a five blade
razor with a lubricating strip and a
trimmer blade although if you like me
you won't need the lubrication no I mean
Gary and you also get a lovely lathering
shave gel plus a travel plate cover for
when you need to go about you need to
look sharp day to day I'm really happy
to trigonometry to be able to offer you
this in conjunction with Harry's so you
get a trial set three pound 95 that is a
trial shaving set for three pound 95 and
the brilliant thing about this offer is
that it gets delivered straight to your
door so you get the shaving handle the
five blade razor the shave gel and the
travel break cover and it's really
simple to claim on this exclusive offer
all you need to do is go to harrys.com
forward slash trigger harry's calm
forward side trigger decline your
exclusive offer and who knows if you
play your cards right you'll end up
looking like me yeah and it's it's
really interesting because that you said
like we've got that desire to show it
down
why where do you think the
counterculture is happening do you think
it's something like comedy on least like
night is it the internet or is it other
things I think it's across its across a
lot of things that's I mean comedy
unleashed but I was a regular Club
nights you can really I think people
think club comedy it's just
junglers as middle-aged guys do dick
jokes which actually as Billy when
people have paid when people have paid
fifteen pounds to go and see comedy like
they'll they'll really stay on board for
you know you can explore some ideas
political ideas socially socio-cultural
ideas and I think it's a good way of
defusing tensions because there is
there's no mention it before but there
is this pervasive feeling amongst you
know certain sections of white British
to say the white British culture is
under attack and that's that's a that's
the thing that's gonna as a feeling
that's gonna have to be acknowledged
dealt with anybody voices anything about
that at the moment is shouted down as a
racist you know I mean actually I was
arguing with somebody today like I said
you know we should make the you know the
guy the hero from the riots who carried
the black guy who carried out the the
white guy possible fascist you know we
don't know but yeah there's a good
chance he was through it you know Nazi
salutes or whatever before that be
carried see if the rest is life to save
this guy it might be ideologically
opposed that might hate him whatever you
know best is this black guy risked his
life to like save this white guy and
it's a beautiful moment and it does so
much to sir you know defuse the tensions
you're sure you know the you know it's
just a beautiful symbolic thing and then
you know see this guy should play the
new James Bond and somebody like him
straight and there are no no white James
point why it's like we've been played by
an Australian and an Irishman you know I
mean like what like address ale but it's
more British than [ __ ] George Lazenby
like but it's this weird I'm always
reppin the pest at this guy for saying
James Bond's got to be white but that is
how people does it some people some
people feel they feel like you know
their tax and although the TV she was
getting taken off and they're all you
know feeds into this narrative of the
sort of white white persecution I mean I
mean it goes out there's obviously
deeper stuff as well like the the rather
and you know grooming gangs and stuff
like that which were you know the report
said the the political correctness
you know what culture was part of those
incidents being ignored and allowed to
carry on over over decades because
people were scared
of looking racist so they allowed
children to be abused
rather than look racist by you know
taking action to do it and also you know
it shows the class is still a huge a
huge injustice in our society you know
because they're white working-class and
they're just ignored there's no you know
there's nobody out there Kate and for
them the scene is you know the the
lowest rung in society and you know I
think that's something that's gotta be
addressed as well it's again because
it's deemed unacceptable to punch down
on certain people but if you punch down
on white working-class people yeah that
gets automatically a big reaction you
know a little round of applause rest of
it and you were mentioning about Rodham
I think the report got released was it
last month and they suppressed it really
yeah yeah they suppressed it right so
again because they're afraid of you know
in flaming you know racial tension yeah
but they're fleeing and then flying in
flaming them more by not releasing it
yeah it's kicking the can down the road
and it's also given you know fueling the
fire of they you know wasn't in Tommy
Robinson and you know although they sort
of far-right people so you know it
really needs to people really need to
acknowledge it and deal with it before
it becomes you know something that feeds
into the far-right I think this is where
the cultural aspect and comedy is part
of this needs to recognize its role in
the sense that if you can only make fun
of certain groups like I know lots of
working-class people who are absolutely
up for being made fun of yeah as long as
so is everybody else
yeah yeah but at the moment you start
saying well you can't go there you can't
go there you can't and only these people
can be the target your job then you're
gonna start to see a fight back there as
well and then who the [ __ ] knows what we
gonna be back to airplane food aren't we
yeah yeah see it's a funny something so
I mean obviously with the lockdown as
well as had a you know a deadly impact
on comedy for some time in this country
why do you see do you think we're gonna
come back this year and when we do do
you think it's going to be completely
different the same like how do you see
it I think it's going to be gradual I
mean there's there's some promoters
putting on drive-in gigs which is a
pretty horrific
I've been glasgow doing them as he stand
on the truck you got a big screen behind
you so everybody can see it but then you
got like all these Glaswegian families
sitting in cars armed with car horns and
from you're not getting to the left of
the feedback laughter from the crowd but
you are gonna get a glass regions going
it's good I don't see you guys keep it
clean because it's families in the cars
so yeah I'm not alarmed I'm gonna do
them because I like money I'm not
looking forward to them and then I think
club shows will start to return I mean a
lot of people are saying they don't they
don't feel comfortable going a comedy
club so you crammed them with so many
people but I mean coronavirus is pretty
much over isn't it it feels like it yeah
it feels like it you know I mean maybe
know if you're 80 but no but but it
seems like the lockdown I mean like
we're recording this in London now I
don't see many people socially
distancing oh yeah yeah that specially
not in this room no you guys can't see
there's about 73 people in here yeah all
the windows and doors a shot we can't
breathe yeah yeah but but yeah I mean it
does seem to be over I guess what I was
asking as well is G like as I was
thinking of you know coming back or
whatever are you thinking you need to
like do things really differently with
comedy or you just you think we just
come back you know you start doing
basically the same stuff you were doing
before with I think I'll probably update
it the one thing this happened is
because I'm doing internet stuff and
recording videos I've been writing a lot
more so thing I think doing stuff on the
internet is great for writings you can't
come out and do the same 20 minutes
every week so so yeah right and stuff
recording it and I think you know it's
great with the internet as well there's
no sort of upper limit I mean my
salary's been fairly sort of constant
because there's only so many Club gigs
you can do so you can you know you're
stuck at you're limited by the I mean
they never pay more than you know like
two 300 quid occasionally you'll get
like you know more than that but you
know you're generally sort of limiting
you can only do like maximum you know
one or two a night so that limits you
whereas with the internet there's no
upper bound on you know how many people
you can fit in the room
so you know think like you guys with
trigonometry which is you know taken off
and call me at least which is taken off
online you know that's that's a way
forward so do you think more and more
that you're gonna be on the internet and
it's in comedy is gonna lose that sort
of live environment
I think the live environment is so
there's nothing nothing's gonna replace
you know being live on stage in front of
people those two stunts mean that's the
sir visceral thrill that thing you know
comedians need that's what I really my
got stood depressed like the first bit
of lock thing because I went from doing
festivals so I was like you know doing
so many shows that day there was so much
fun and then like you know straight to
nothing it was horrible and then you get
an occasional like zoom gig or whatever
you're just shooting a laptop when you
switch the laptop off and you're just
like [ __ ] an audience is the same I
think people you know they want to be in
the live environment as well there's
nothing you can't beat that for sure
yeah
but he's something about human nature we
want people around us we want that
communal experience right yeah yeah
absolutely but but equally I think a lot
of people are scared too
yeah does this predict what we've like
Francis was saying they've been
terrified for three months so stay at
home I'm done you know yeah maybe the
whole protest and the riots might open
their eyes that was the turning point
for me man because I followed every
single thing to the letter and then the
moment well I did like an idiot and then
you wake up and there's like thousands
of people industry and you go yeah I
mean maybe this it wasn't all that real
yeah yeah
oh man it's interesting times isn't it
interesting times what was the question
the comedy is gonna be after after
cruelty yeah yeah yeah I mean I think
the Internet's vinton is good but the
trouble with all this internet stuff is
you got to really work at it you must
really hard do all the editing and only
said he's organizing people to get in a
room you know I mean I can I can't
organize stuff if I could organize stuff
I'd get a normal job and spend like the
only thumb so remotely qualified for his
get on stage and shouting and I need a
deadline to get anything done and a gig
as
in bill deadlines you got to get a gig
and do it well I'm gonna record videos
and edit them and upload them and do
subtitles and stuff is such a pain in
the ass you know
tell me about it but let's talk a little
bit about hating live as well would you
like an improvised show that you you do
with another comedian I'm glad we didn't
mention yeah let's not mention but is
that something do you think can like
just tell people what it is and it will
take maybe talk about it yeah so
basically eating live is sure that I run
with Darius TVs and it's assertive air
you know there's there's a you know
censorship in comedy and you got to be
careful what you see this this pushes
the line we over because what we do is
we get the audience to give us
suggestions and then the communities of
the get on stage and hate on whatever
that suggestion is so it's coming from
the audience that they'll accept you
know far more evil stuff and that we
don't have you just came out and started
seeing that stuff at normal game and
it's just got a brilliant atmosphere and
we've been doing it for ages no like
seriously like eight years or something
like that and we take it to those
trailing fast tools and the N brofist
when we turn the country this year it's
really probably fun I was thinking
whether you could you could do that
online but then I remember some of the
comments they even we get and I'm sure
that's good but have you thought about
doing something like that maybe like
with TV or online or something yeah yeah
we thought about doing it and then turns
out were lazy so which i think is an
important step but yeah we are gonna do
some we were due to record a show call
me Unleashed yeah yeah before Karuna
verb in a coruña virus you know hey and
we can't do that and but yeah I think I
think it might work online you know if
you did it on like a zoom thing I mean
the really exciting thing about about
hating life it's really transgressive so
you know you get the improvised topic
and someone pulls something out like
yeah I don't know like little babies or
whatever it is and then you've got a hit
or although you've got to say why
pedophiles are brilliant yeah and
immediately you can see the crowd just
go this is something really exciting
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it almost feels
like a complete antidote to you know
bland TV comedy where you're just
sitting
I know what you're gonna say yeah how
you're gonna say I know what the punch
yes I can't believe they haven't put it
on TV with Wizards we're talking at BBC
Studios about doing it I've been talking
to the other TV producers and it's like
is such an obviously simple format that
just works and you can do it in a sort
of it almost works as a certain more
genteel show than our so late night
rowdy live show
we've done it in Bengal clubs and you
know all sorts of venues where you've
got to let you know scale it down a
little bit Marx is so you know more
radio fourth type short as well but it's
just so much fun and there's just that
tension in the air and then the release
when the comedian it's obviously the
community they've got the heat on
something are they good to see where
they love pedophiles nobody's gonna come
out there's that wouldn't be the people
hunters okay in the Midlands I can't
remember what his name was but my
brilliant I love it when I love
communities get caught by Peter hunt
this is the best nothing's more
entertaining than seeing a colleague
cancel I've got my favorite of the the
work comedians who praise International
Women's Day was when you know about
their dating history and their
reputation with women yeah yeah yeah
yeah well remember Chris Kuehl tree is
always a sexually assaulted women you
ran a comedy they just allegedly
allegedly oh we had some run-ins with
defamation and libel recently so we have
to say that we have no actual evidence
that Chris Coltrane assaulted women
except the woman who called him out on
Twitter saying that he'd assaulted
though him immediately left comedy and
closed down his Twitter account his
website and social media is coincidence
even Michael Jackson held on in there
yeah but Michael Jackson was good at
music rule isn't it like if someone goes
on about how much of a male feminist
they are yeah they've been dippin
nefarious behind-the-scenes I'm yeah
yeah another thing is when Jesus at and
sorry when he got he got in trouble for
basically you know we went on a date
with this lassie and and and he's so he
got his [ __ ] ooh and you know was trying
to like you just really started treating
her like a piece of meat and like trying
to try to [ __ ] her like but with no
charm you heard somebody have you heard
their you know something from motley
crue doing that you'd be like yeah what
you know I mean like yeah motley crue
because he's gonna get his dick it but
Chris Aziz Ansari had been like oh yeah
I'm a FEMINIST and even written books
about how to date and how to respect
women like a it was worse much worse
coming from I think that's what we need
to bring back you know a good
old-fashioned honest misogyny sorry
shouldn't feel the need to do these
books on famine ISM and stuff just you
don't come out and met yeah of this I
see women as objects and I'm gonna put
my dick in them and then like when at
least women know women know when they're
going to eat with them ladies gonna get
his caucus there's a woman in the room
is laughing hell yeah but it's it's
transparent advertised yeah she's gotta
be honest about what you want yes yeah
none of this like you know a treat
descriptions act well in the family is
Mike do you know we do um on these
interviews so we we also got a thing
called trigger Clips where we clip
little bits of the interview right just
some and put it on without any context
I'm gonna put that that's gonna be the
title as well but is it some we laugh
about it but it's also embracing isn't
it the utter of rank hypocrisy of these
people yeah and then because the general
probably takes them at face value and
they go like we all know the one can
particularly
I mean whoever he goes he's such a nice
guy in your life no he's not
is that we'll say afterwards this so
many of them well I mean there's the
rule in comedy if somebody's a nice
person on stage there are cut off stage
as Darius told deck on stage like nicest
guy in the world or stage but you know
it's interesting I was finding
interesting just having chats with
comedians because I think like obviously
comedians to have a [ __ ] idea what
we're talking about to some extent but
on the other hand there's also a level
of sensitivity to the culture because
like you say the audience is always
giving you feedback about like what's
acceptable was not so what do you kind
of see in terms of the cultural moment
that we're in like what are we going to
become more woke or more worried about
like offending people or is there gonna
be like a massive backlash against that
where you're gonna see people maybe
going back to doing like really
outrageous stuff that's maybe actually
too far like how do you see the moment
they're wearing well they've been
pushing walk comedy for quite a while
now
and some of it sort of taken off and
become popular lejana Gadsby for example
but the comedians that are still making
the big bucks
like Ricky Gervais Dave Chappelle bill
bar the ones that are like you know
proper you know can fell it Riina's and
make loads of money with our Netflix
specials they're not walk so I mean it's
almost like a fashion that's you know
it's making a lot of noise but it's not
I feel like we're at the tail end of it
like it's like Bret pop when men's wear
camo you know then it all like fell down
and a pack of cards a thing I think
we're gonna see I mean
aunty what comedy never went away it's
always there like Dave Chappelle you
know all these people they're not walk I
think the reason that it's felt like
that to us to a large extent is that
people like Chappelle chivay set such
are they independent they can do
whatever they want then your cancelable
was for the for us it's much more a case
of like well if you say the wrong thing
or you know people look at your Facebook
and you said something didn't like then
you're not gonna get put four clubs and
that's your livelihood
yeah so it feels very different so I
think that
where a lot of the discrepancy comes in
is you if you want non-work comedy you
can go and buy a ticket for 50 or 100
pounds and see the Bilbo's the ricky
gervais but if you go to a comedy club I
mean it's all work to a very logic so
there's a few exceptions but Jeff I
think in London maybe you know but then
the bigger clubs I wouldn't say it as
walk I think you know it's much more
like Belle bar or Chapelle or you know
something like that they want I mean the
bigger clubs they want people coming in
spending money having a good time going
away and coming back so they put on good
people instead of walk people I've never
seen there aren't good walk comedians
but I just can't think of any reason so
we've wondering how many bits of this
episode we're done none yeah you go with
Bebo cress Coltrane's name we were we
were gonna be sued by a very prestigious
lesbian magazine yeah Graham Linehan
when we had him on the show said the
diva magazine was a lesbian magazine for
men
yeah where's it's a lesbian magazine for
trans people yeah all right so he was
being transphobic saying like yeah but
he was joking and all of us left of his
right as transphobia is funny
but but what he said was a joke and then
they pretended that it was meant
literally and threatened to sue us yeah
yeah so from that moment on we try not
to say things that are true yeah I'm
surprised that green Lenna all these
people they are using their voices to
sort of kick transgender people you know
I mean because they're the most you know
like they're the Musa vilified is that
the only sector Society apart from like
white working-class people that is okay
to openly sort of there be she ate it
like an it's still it's still a big
problem so that's not very funny but
like you know a final of the
of the Jilin uh I just I don't know why
otherwise doing it I don't get it well I
don't I don't get why he's got a like a
bee in his bonnet for transgender people
I mean I totally get you know there's
it's a difficult issue in certain ways
that like you know there's there's
changes that could be exploited
nefariously like you know well it's an
issue of women's rights layer is that
you exactly you can't just have a gay
being able to put on a frock and go in a
you know women's spaces but then on the
other hand like Danny the lastly idea
it's like absolutely stunning totally
looks like a look like a woman if she if
she was in the men's toilets people be
like what the [ __ ] you did it and so I
mean where this will is grim when and
draw the line does he have a hotness
rule no I mean look that conversation is
one where there's a lot of militancy on
both sides yeah and we've had people on
from from all sides to talk about III
think there's people who think who feel
very strongly that it's about protecting
women yeah and there's people who feel
very strongly that it's about preventing
discrimination against trans people
which we all support you know we were
joking about it but of course we do yeah
so I guess it's about finding middle
ground and we don't seem to be in a time
where anyone wants to find middle ground
on any issue yeah and in such a nuanced
issue and is almost a case-by-case basis
but yeah I mean the hopefully the
government you know bring it through
legislation that's gonna you know deal
with it but I actually think a lot of
the pushback against some of the
excesses of the trans lobby has now
resulted in the fact that the
legislation you're talking about which
is the gender accreditation act they've
taken out a lot of the stuff that was
just like what you're talking about
right I'm a woman right yeah it's gone
now self ID that's gone right that was
the stuff that people are pushing back
against but I think for some people like
everybody has an issue where they're
like this is the thing and I'm gonna
tweet about it every [ __ ] day and
this is my thing you know and I think
people can get stuck in that militancy a
little bit yeah I think it's probably a
social media thing more than anything I
mean social media is just not helping
right now
there's the Rodney King riots you know
at least there were social media wasn't
amplifying the the worst voices on each
side you know late and you know you're
just hearing from neo-nazis and from you
know militant auntie auntie for people
and they're you know people pick the
extremes to show you know the voices
that get shown you know so somebody can
grab there and Tifa voice and say look
this is what this is what this side of
like somebody can grab you know the new
and I see voices be like this is what
these people are like when they're just
the the very narrow slivers on the
extreme ends of the dicks yeah
Constantine is doing very well I've got
four thousand followers on Instagram I
was looking there's a there's a chicken
that doesn't really fear those this
chicken that doesn't have any fear those
just running about looking like a mad
chicken when you affair those it's got
like 60,000 followers chicken with no
feathers do you like this chicken it
doesn't affair those he thought like me
and do you think audiences have become
more sin seriously or would you just
think it's an emboldened minority
well it certainly seem alike chickens at
no I don't think audiences I mean
certainly some audiences I mean about
people in audiences the you know the do
you get walk out say it shows oh yeah I
got walk outs get walk out to get
walk-ins
yeah but the jump off stage and throw
people under me did a free friend you
name but you don't have security or
anything's you got to do it yourself
but actually I mean to be fair like
walking out of a comedy show you know
they couldn't just be walking out cuz a
[ __ ] no I mean the worst thing about
worst thing is when they ste and like
just you know like stay and try and like
you know [ __ ] with this short I knew
that I had one of those in their number
last year but yeah I guess what I'm
saying you know just talking about
audiences is like I think people you
know people have a right not to like a
show and walk out that's not the
censorship you get the money
the people not liking the show comedy is
very subjective mmm so then like I know
why people come and sure that it's like
you know called right-wing comedians
like wait a minute this is comedians
seen these right-wing oh my good boys
lower taxes a smaller covering over
could this case where people do that
like you know where I wouldn't see less
than women see jealous other words
[ __ ] loads of people walked out and
it's like what did you think European
25-pound to see do you think people
enjoy that working out though they get
some kind of superiority I get to have
that performative moment where they you
know make the voice make the make their
feelings show in their opinions sure my
[ __ ] social media for that I'm going
to tweet their disgust
so you know you get people following
your own social media just just to hey I
get people follow me on social media and
then they're like comment on the mat
we'd say this is disgusting and stuff
and I'm like well thanks for engaging
with it you know
and they're like I actually we're ratio
eating you so you've got more like
comments than likes or whatever yeah and
you talk about being right-wing comedian
is that more of like a marketing thing
for you or is it really very much like
that's who you are the two you've always
been like I'm not saying you're being
fake or anything I guess I'm just saying
like did you feel like you had to lean
into that persona a little bit more to
stand out so you think I'm being fake I
think I mean you know part of its
marketing part of is giving a short
getting a show idea and then you can
then write funny stuff because I felt
like writing funny stuff all these like
you know BBC writing rooms where they're
like hey what's the angle wing-t Donald
Trump's an idiot you know I mean that's
not funny
Donald Trump's it also it's not [ __ ]
true - case go like what four point four
billion dollars he's got like big
skyscrapers with his name on them you
know it bangs porn stars this guy's not
an idiot this guy's the [ __ ] dream
legend like yeah these comedian scene is
an idea you know it's a bad business but
no he's a great business man I tell you
what a bad business for me dude but
become a comedian and assure the end but
a fringe lose loads of money nicely you
know I know I just find there's more
opportunity for humor you know being
being right Hwang and playing devil's
advocate that way and you know from a
realistic point of view I worked in
policing and a work in government for a
long time and I just saw how nepotistic
and corrupt
everything is and I just believe in
smaller government and you know fewer
resources flowing into the government
and the whole idea of socialism is that
you know some apparatchik behind a desk
can spend your money better than you can
you know I mean and I support that for
things like the health health system
like nationalized health care is just
better is more efficient you know just
you get a better service and it
shouldn't be some of this that's done
for profit but for other things like
councils you know just expanding the
rules we're way out of you know what
they should just you know keep the
streets clean and you know collect the
bends that's all they need to do schools
and stuff they don't need to do anything
else
spoken like a true Nazi well thanks for
coming on Leo thank you you've got
nothing to plug I imagine at this point
no you can follow me on youtube like Leo
cares
I've got like 5,000 followers on YouTube
now yeah make sure we'll put the link to
the channel put the link in so people
can follow you very funny guy and Leo
the last question we always ask is what
is the one thing that we aren't talking
about that we should be talking about I
wrote something down forgot what it was
oh yeah dealing with well I didn't know
I was gonna have to answer the question
you see no there's gonna be a little
later no we did actually tell them we've
got we got an exam we've got exam at
school you turn up oh we're going exam
revised you know interviews don't
normally have questions nobody's
nobody's talking about I mean I think
that I think a big problem going forward
is going to be the the sort of the white
British feeling of culture and values
and you know heritage being under attack
and with war memorials defaced TV she
was getting taken off and you know
understand those things weren't done to
for that reason but I think you know
that feeling of white British culture
being under attack is gonna is gonna
fuel the rise of the far right so it
needs to be dealt with you know they
need to be brought into the to the
conversation just made not to feel
pariahs
not the fuel outcasts well maybe we
should stop attacking white British
culture that would be like a simple fix
to that issue
ya know defacing war memorials live if
there's grooming gangs then deal with
them quickly and effectively
sounds pretty rad extremely right
the things to deal with that you know
are pretty pretty nice things to do so I
can't say can you what do you think it
would be the response from what from the
government from society to that issue
to that issue I mean I'm not I'm not
sure to be honest I love to see how
things sail but I mean given the the
sort of what happened in Saturday
weather I was shocked by the by the you
know neo Nazi salutes and stuff that was
really like shocking to me and really so
abhorrent and I was like I felt really
sick like much worse than you know so
the call is what talking points push the
video on YouTube and somebody pushed
underneath ability we need to get these
funny well on that happy note Leah
thanks for coming on me just good to see
you and make sure you go follow Leah's
very very funny and he likes to rub the
wrong Peter the right with the right
people that's transforming he likes to
rub the right people the wrong way
I like to intentionally I like to rub
the wrong penises the right way yeah
exactly
absolutely especially his own thank you
very much for watching we'll see you
very soon with another interview live
stream taker absolutely next time we'll
make sure to do an intellectual on guys
for those thinking it was gonna be an
intellectual one see you next week
I could have talked about policing
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word